that the Netherlands now with 120
million pieces of cattle
is the mega stable of Europe and that it is untenable
if you say so
The Netherlands is the largest mega-stable in the world
here the farmers
our farmers
work the most sustainable in the whole world
cannot keep talking to each other
but I also keep talking
no Mrs. van der class
you will find them all
because it you see them
so you see all farmers
just like guardians of 1 mega stable
that says we are going to put words in the mouth
may i maybe
I would appreciate it if you were ma'am
van der Plas is going to finish talking go ahead
our farmers are the most sustainable in the world
people from abroad
come and see how we do that
how we put so much on such a small stamp
be able to make sustainable affordable food
they come here to learn from us
and then I hear the Lord jets recently in 1 debate
yes but we can also export our knowledge
mister jets
if there is no farmer left,
that knowledge is also gone